oh yeah this might review for Punishers
season two I feel like there might be
some spoilers in here too spoiler
warning I don't know for sure I'm
filming this part at the beginning of
the review but if I keep it in that
means they're things in here I consider
spoilers so you've been warned a
[Music]
Punisher Season 2 so the Punisher season
2 is season 2 of Netflix is plunger
probably also the last season I didn't
review season 1 I know I feel like I
don't have to in order to review season
2 I didn't ever review season 1 the
answer is simple because it I just
didn't grab me fans critics everyone's
like you're gonna blow a load over this
if you don't you should I was like I
don't know it just kind of seems like
Otacon and snake hanging out but less
interesting other than the last four
episodes the show just didn't really
grab me season 2 did so I'm talking
about season 2 so season 2 of The
Punisher like most any Marvel Netflix
show is actually a couple plots going on
there's the Billy Russo versus Frank
Castle thing and there's this religious
fanatic hitman guy he's like Javier
Bardem from No Country for Old Men but
instead of that thing that they used to
put down cows that it kills people with
as a normal gun instead of that haircut
he has pseudo-intellectual Bible
passages but whenever Amish paradise
there was on scene causing problems
those damn entertained same with Billy
Russo and usually I'm of the mindset
that RM Nisha plotlines they suck and
they're lazy and I don't like them it's
like ever since Smallville everyone
always lost their memory to forget Clark
Kent's powers from Smallville annals
like alright that's just lazy a
storytelling
so Billy Russo of course has amnesia in
season 2 he doesn't remember what he did
in season 1 but I actually felt like
that made for an interesting dynamics to
him he's not the villian doesn't
remember to him Frank castles the
villain ease this scary ass terminator
coming after him in fact all the
villains in here are some form of mirror
on Frank Castle I found that really cool
cuz Frank Castle is not a nice guy at
all he has a code yeah and I respect
that and if push comes to shove I'd want
Frank castle to have buyback but to a
lot of people he's pretty [ __ ]
hardcore and he's hardcore in this show
that's what I like about this show
showed us and pulled punches literally
at all its hyper violent but the
Punisher it elevates the violence yes
you can elevate violence Mortal Kombat
is testament to that look at that
fatality tell me that's not art and the
Punisher Season 2 does the same [ __ ] and
ever Frank Castle is dispatching anyone
and very creative if not very quick ways
I guess the quick kills are the best
we're just like done I just damn
entertained
I just think Billy Russo should have his
face more [ __ ] up I mean he's jigsaw
like the scars on his face in season 2
were kind of a mild inconvenience
they're like nah but he's so pretty we
got the shell
granted its 2019 in terms of plastic
surgery there have been strides you can
make a pretty busted up face look pretty
normal now but also begs the question
why like why they even do that just
because they can do that doesn't mean
they would do that what doctors gonna be
like a he's a murdering [ __ ] we all
know that but you know what we'll put in
the manpower
we'll put Humpty Dumpty back together
again why not but I guess if his face
looked like the lovechild between
Deadpool and a hundred piece jigsaw
puzzle he wouldn't get that chick so
alright whatever this will keep him
pretty with a couple scars so what gets
the party started is these people are
trying to kill this girl Frank Castle
kills them instead or kills a couple
severely incapacitates a couple others
twenty she's running from bad guys the
Frank Castle is gonna help her out
because that's what Frank Castle does he
protects people he takes out baddies he
lives for the fight he lives for the war
and then Billy Russo comes back and has
to deal with that both of these plots
they interested me the Billy Russo one
more than Amish paradise I don't know
like you call him that cuz it's weird
Alice and [ __ ] author and a poet
that's why if I had to pick one I'd pick
Billy Russo keep him he's the one more
interconnected with the agencies is more
personal at springboarding office season
one so it makes more sense
I do wish some of the agents had a
better arc like agent Madonna's back I
mean season one I felt she was one of
the weaker parts season two she's
actually quite good but there are two
kinds of cliches that make me feel like
oh you did that one is amnesia and the
others got shot in the head and still
lived this show does both of those but
for some of the other agents and cops I
wanted to see more of them because this
is one cop in here he's kind of a dick
but he's a good cop and he's like now
Frank castles killing people got to
bring him in and I wanted to see more of
his struggle with that you know
eventually he's gonna come around a bit
like alright maybe he's not so bad maybe
the lines are blurred here and there he
doesn't really know how to deal with
that so he just comes across as a dick
he wants to take Frank Castle down I
wanted to see more of that more of that
dynamic in here that could have been
like the front and center as it stands
is kind of a side note and if that other
arc that's not the Billy Russo arc like
crazy religious hitman guy arc if that
had to take more of a backseat to make
this one front and center I'd have told
have been fine with that fact the public
should have done that and then show like
every Netflix Marvel show it shouldn't
be 13 episodes long they should commit
to a couple arcs and make it like 10 as
it stands right now you take three
episodes so that's what three hours I
can think of three hours of filler that
could go away to make this show feel
tighter in the end some of the arcs the
way they wrapped up it was just pretty
abrupt this is where the spoilers come
in so you have been warned you were
warned at the beginning but crazy
religious hitman just kind of goes away
it doesn't matter the damage this dude
cause it just kind of goes away granted
the ones pulling the string they paid
for it but you
you either have to make that dude pay
for it also or make me really feel like
oh he's absolved of all wrongdoing and I
don't feel either he just kind of goes
away I feel like there was a bit of
misrepresentation there there was a
story perpetuating at the beginning of
the month saying that he's alright he's
a religious fanatic who murders people
sure but in terms of all right but
different than that the show does
illustrate that he has a past tied into
that but as he stands right here it's
not like he's a neo-nazi or some [ __ ] I
just feel like that story was
perpetuated because well that's a very
topical story and that'll get views
that'll get hits that click and after
seeing the show I personally find it a
bit irresponsible let people go in there
and see the character and assess the
character themselves let the character
present themselves to the audience how
the character does don't misrepresent
the character or skew people's
perceptions of the character before they
even see the show as take clickbait be
[ __ ] like that when people misrepresent
characters like that in articles and
they just run with qlik matey [ __ ] then
people make youtube videos reacting to
the reactions and it just snowballs
there was a snowball of [ __ ] the
beginning of January they're just really
after watching this season
it's not even grounded in reality the
character is a bit different than that
yeah whatever in the end I thought the
Punisher season 2 was great it was a
great binge it has great fights exciting
shootouts bloody satisfaction if that's
what you're coming to the Punisher for
if you realize who the Punisher is
you'll have a good time with it we're
like I've seen reviews of people who are
just like guns of the state age yeah
it's the Punisher people die I just wish
the story arcs flowed together a bit
more rather than feeling like a couple
of compartmentalised story arcs I feel
like there are two kinds of people in
the world people who will watch season 2
over season one is he's one over season
two I personally I like season two over
season one but even if the Marvel
Netflix shows weren't getting cancelled
I would still feel like this is dead
show walking Frank Castle does not
exactly conform with the perspective of
civilized Hollywood tweeters he's a dude
who's angry judge jury executioner
execute people with guns
he's like everything top tier Hollywood
tweeters hate but I think the Punisher
season 2 was a good watch is a great
binge worth binging so binging or so the
Punisher season 2 have you seen it what
did you think about it or what do you
prefer season 2 or season 1 whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]